what would you like to know about the
rib does it sting it draws blood
it was very
graceful and elegant and actually very
dance-like and beautiful and kind of
feel more feline really and it
contributed a great deal to the part a
lot of things i did got reaction on this
movie
my first week was like this my boots
weren't right and i was i couldn't walk
in them because i kept tilting forward
and my mask was smashing my face and i
couldn't hear and it was cutting off my
vocal cords
and
i couldn't really breathe in the corset
and then they would have all of these
lights in my way and i would have to
then change on the spot
what i was what i had planned and what
kind of routine i had planned with my
whip and then i had to act how could you
i'm a woman
i'm sorry i
i grew up with the television series
and um
i used to watch it religiously basically
waiting for catwoman to come on i
purloined it from the library she was
never on enough as far as i was
concerned
[Music]
meow it was really well written you know
and much more complicated
and interesting
than i had even hoped for
at all and and you know and tim is is he
creates
the most
beautiful kind of
sweet and sinister characters it's just
a real departure for me ever since they
made the first batman i i
really wanted to play catwoman who are
you
who's the man behind the bed
maybe you can help me find
the woman
behind the cat
we talked about
when she uses her sexuality as a
manipulation when she's being happy when
she's
being sexual for real because that is
the part of you know
selena kyle character in a film today
you have a lot more freedom to make it
more sexually you're the second man who
killed me this week
but i've got seven lives left
i had such a good time making this movie
i mean it was hard and i it was
one of the hardest things i've ever done
without a doubt
but at the same time i had a really good
time and when i saw the finished product
i was so proud to be in
one of tim's
me
films
[Music]